hi my name is Ashley Wong and I work
with Cale so my project is to enable
data data visualization for mobile
humanitarian Technologies there are
three main parts to my project the first
is App Inventor which is a open-source
block based program in order to allow
non-coders to be able to develop Android
apps the second part is going to be the
Puna interface which is an MIT research
group headed by Lana kagle this is kind
of more uh humanitarian focused and and
this is the department that I'm working
with the third piece of my project is my
super Europe op so my super EUR op is to
create a data visualization component to
add to the Puna interface currently
there's no way for the Puna interface to
allow users to input some data some data
set and move blocks around and output a
graph this is a problem that I intend to
address so I've been uh going through
several data visualization libraries and
researching which ones are the best in
order to create this component and this
is kind of the list of the data visual
libraries that I've been looking
at So currently I'm around here on the
time timeline which means I am about
halfway done with my first prototype so
that's exciting and I hope to be able to
go through about three iterations by the
end of next year